this is the deep end which you have
certainly gone off of this is one of my
personal favorites I love this one the
inflatable duck revolution has begun and
that the thing at the credits is
actually a is something in Spanish but
translates out to long live the
inflatable ducks
you're free you're free so this is an
episode where a super hot everybody goes
to the pool and all sorts of adventures
and weird stuff happened stan has a
fight for his perfect chair with Gideon
great to see him back um
dipper tries to become an assistant
lifeguard with Wendy with this crazy
lifeguard who you saw on the bar earlier
and it's just enjoyably insane he eats
whistles and the main focus is that
Mabel has a new boyfriend who is of
course a merman it's our you even
surprised anymore um mermen doh mom
that's a great character and it is
really funny sort of like you know sort
of the epic you know Mexican that has
this long history tells the story with
the guitar and so forth is just I am a
mysterious loner I must leave you go to
him
lock resuce lines in this yeah he's
really funny already but it's like some
really good lines in this one um and
it's free Mercer is trying to get her
mando back home and while everyone else
is trying to balance out their stories
and that's that's really about it but
it's one of those were every single time
that cuts back to a different story
going on I just start laughing cuz I
love the setup so much every time it
cuts to stay in like in pool Jail of the
crazy lifeguard yeah the crazy lifeguard
the the poor kid you know in the pool
through the little solitary cab oh my
gosh that is amazing the nights are the
toughest night senator heart these are
the closing credits like the closing
credits are usually okay there's some
sort of cute jokers and his lighting
they threw out all the see yeah and then
the fireworks on the fourth of July and
he pulls up the little flag and waves
oh when he eats the chip that's floating
in the pool on that note like mirando
just like how long have you been under
the water long enough and she calls up a
band-aid I like to think that's
mcgucket's a band-aid or the old guy I
never know if I'm seeing his name right
I'm probably not and I'm sure I'll be
told damn person but yeah there's just
something about this one about the the
energy I love the idea just there being
a merman in this pool and I love the
sending the bottles at the end I mean
there shouldn't be can it be true we've
caught some sort of man fish but it is
lash such as our beautiful man fish eat
is Felicia she's flesh um
the cops once again here every day with
you is a dream that cracks me up I'll I
actually you know I've said Wendy
occasionally and she's not my favorite
character but for some reason I really
liked her in this episode
no she doesn't she was very funny loved
good I make the rules usually yeah she's
attacking me with water yeah I get it
she'll get a stand in the prison cut
style kind of a swimsuit how long are
you in yes yeah two hours but I'm told
my innocence yeah when they play up that
angle like her getting fired and not
carrying you know cuz she kept stealing
snacks that's only reason she took the
job like that that angles great I love
when they play that off you know and
it's funny because in some ways I would
kind of like look at the fact like oh
well Mabel's the loopy character and
she's always really flirtatious and like
it you know normally that would kind of
bug me because I'm just like in lesser
shows that would be like kind of a
throwaway character like oh that's her
thing she's a whore okay but it balances
out because dippers got the exact same
thing going it's just he's only
interested in one girl but it's the the
two of them have the exact same thing
going it's just she's interested in
everybody and dippers interested in
Wendy why Jack and I love that little
bit at the end where he's like she's
like haven't you ever you know
completely fallen for somebody and you
know it's probably gonna break
heart eventually but you know you did
and he's like you know you could see the
look on his face like he's like yeah
Wendy well but but what I like too is
like you said it's Mabel's personality
is such an extrovert that you know it's
just anyone she'll give her heart to
kind of anyone and that's kind of a
problem we're with dipper he's a bit
more introverted so he'll like find one
person but you know but again give his
heart to her but it's only that one
person and but that's kind of misleading
you know to disaster as well uh so yeah
I think it bounces out fine um I'm
trying to think what else I mean this
was one of those where it's like it's
kinda like what we said before where
there's so many funny moments I tried to
remember them doing crap till the little
creeper oh my cheeks are like smacking
babies cheeks that that's probably that
there's a few millions that pop up in
this show that he probably is my
favorite villain uh because like I said
he's so you yeah he's like he's kind
he's kind of gross but he's also got
kind of his you know like he can play a
crowd too so he's very charming but he
can also be very diabolical and mean he
can be very smart he can be very stupid
and like this
yeah it's is a lot of fun um and uh
probably about it I gotta try things
learned stuff like I really like this
episode but it's one of those were it's
like everything kind of speaks for
itself um I really like the voice I've
been behind a ver mando whoever did him
um like I said there's just something I
I like how they can make up rules like
how you know it's like always hope error
showing the hurts we have like 17 oh
yeah that it's horrifying I know but
true
um the worse
we're Mabel like once again maples my
favorite character where she's showing
him the scrapbook it's like and this is
us you know doing this it wouldn't it be
so weird not to have legs
yes let's skip this part oh and here's
my family kick box uh so I really liked
it I liked what they could do with this
one location I mean really everything
pretty much happens in this one spot
just the pool yeah you think
we get really boring but they create
these early Flay stories going on in
even over a couple days and just made a
really entertaining so uh yeah I I've I
was great fun a really enjoyable episode
um too many funny moments to count just
watch again enjoy and uh yeah just have
fun with it all over again
so yeah stellen seen dipper goes to Taco
Bell and I'm happy
why you gotta watch at some point life
is good before I see dipper goes to talk
about
can't avoid it forever done yes I gave
you half a bottle of scotch I drank the
other half of the bottle too you know
cranberry twincest no I was gonna say
prepare yourself for difficult time know
you're watching that one the half a
bottle of scotch I drank was to get rid
of the twincest I'm just gonna tell you
right now cuz era was gonna be like
Wigan legit it's not gonna be in this
loop okay it's not gonna be Co we're
watching these in a row it's I'm not
gonna stop everything for tipper go so
you don't have a computer right over
there you could look I don't know how
long it is it could be like hours fry oh
my guess whatever put this together
could be crazy enough to make it out
it's on YouTube it's 10 minutes or less
Doug they over no excuses maybe you know
all those were like befores they got the
thing and man up dude no excuses I'm not
watching at this you're watching dipper
goes to Taco Bell
cuz I'm not well if you put it like that
no you look ridiculous
you